a near takeaway by the Hawks in the attacking Zone
it's Monahan with the pass to Anderson on the wing
Anderson to The Middle on the backand it's scooped
up by morazzi his glove looks good Banger no
score the puck deflected off Saar the big
defenseman for Montreal mat on the opposite
side mat working his way in close and moric the
safe pulls it off the boards beats two guys oh
goes right to the middle nobody goes towards him
mat leads Monahan and kinsky flips the puck behind
the net a takeaway and a big save by moric on
Jake Evans and a big save on the other end by
Peter morazzi Puck picked off the weak Side by
struble and tenori drops it down and whistle
safe bro rebound B I and from his own net strubel
kept it out let's take a look at this turnover
great play by Tor to keep that puck in with that
Long Reach of his and certainly the goalie must
have thought he was going to pass it to bili I
think that's why bili reacted like he reacted
our ring Camp sponsored by Lexus experience
amazing with Conor Bard for Donado he shoots he
scores no doubt about that one one nothing
Hawks they just weren't going in and if you
keep to it and you get opportunities of course
playing with these two guys as well and this
is a good wrist shot he has got a good wrist
shot always has and he gets this one through
the stick underneath and through the goal tender
and beats him cleanly right there look at that
reaction and the pass just kept inside the Zone
scrubble drops his stick the puck out to Center
Colin Blackwell with another chance stop on a
dime in the slot a score for Jason Dickinson
and the Hawks beautiful drop off pass for
Colin Blackwell holy jump but I guess so
had the patience and presence of mind right
here as he's getting cut off there to take it
to the back end but that's not it now he waits
and waits now I'm thinking he's going to shoot
it no slides it between the legs of Gallagher
who is looking to the skies he can't believe
that Blackwell just did this right there to
there to thanks for coming what a Play What a
play Just mesmerizing watching the replay of
that for Dickinson that's his 10th goal of the
season a career high see around him once he
got that on the back hand I'm thinking he's
going to shoot the puck for sure kept waiting
and a dazzling play by Colin Blackwell here's
Savard a shot from Deep by mat and Montreal
scor that's a set Faceoff play right there and
again the offense derived from the defenseman
right there and there's one Stevens ends up
winning the faceof and now you see SAR puts
it right back to the leftand at mat and you
can see the blade turning over there of Stevens
if you can focus on that part of it 13 who wins
the face off goes to the front of the net
beats his man gets in a good position and
is perfectly hit the fat part kinsky in the
circle in front for Kev and the puck taken by
Monahan whereas Bard comes in as a generational
player a phenomenal player Monahan redirect
score an impressive goal very Suddenly by Montreal
and they have tied this game Josh Anderson it's
now two to2 we he had all kinds of time and all
kinds of patience in front of the net but here
we see from above the ice R there the drop pass
there and what a pass that is over to Anderson
but look at you got two defensemen right there
to the same side of the ice oh boy your right
D is already there and the left D kinsky end up
just kind of floating over there Dickinson with
Blackwell Dickinson shoots off the post rebound
Dickinson Murphy holds the zone for Felino Murphy
to the net Primo stopped the puck Felino does a
great job of protecting the puck banking it off
the glass and Dickinson read it perfectly so
now you got to at first an odd man break and
then was caught up on good back checking by a
situation where they could have made a play out
of that but the Hawks regroup and got it out of
his Zone kicked by gie Suzuki Suzuki gets the puck
back from the circle SLI kovski puts it in and
Montreal has the lead 3 to2 then three unanswered
goals by the road team and the Canadians coming
on here and now after Suzuki looked like it was
a neutral face off the Hawks get possession but
it's played back to the point ghouly just plays
it down again and and now the the Canadians are
really doing a good job of circling and movement
constant motion right here and then you can see
this shot is somewhat blocked and there is that
former number one overall draft pick Sosi that
just slides that in there on a slow moving Puck
and it ends up right in front of them shouting
from the benches there they're looking for too
many men on the ice but that that was not the case
Kev bradish for Johnson what a stop by Primo the
communications going pretty well for the Montreal
Canadians and the Hawks trying to counter right
now with a little three on two break rate here
keep your eye on number 11 radish is playing
that raate to oh my goodness what a redirection
on the backand and it's in midair great hands
there by Tyler Johnson and mat by sovi now and
a top line of forwards on the ice for Montreal
Blackwells SL kovsky Caufield save mazic rebound
Suzuki he scores and it's four to2 Montreal one
quick play and it looked like Coffield that's
his 10th goal of the year he got his ninth
last night 29 Points now for Suzuki in the shot
rebound good save there and just a better play
by 14 coming into the pitcher the young Captain
there's the shot there's a save and obviously
moric commits to a forehand shot right here and
instead Suzuki calmly plays that to the backand
before Dickinson can get to him deflating for the
Hawks absolutely led to nothing at one point and
it's Evans going for more a redirect and another
goal Evans will get credit for it it's a play they
knew they were taking taking on some water after
three consecutive unanswered goals by the Habs in
the second period but now pulling the puck off the
boards one battles there and then Evans takes this
one and goes off the glove and just has enough to
go over top and then beyond the goal line right
there but give Anderson plenty of credit Anderson
scored the goal to tie the game up at two and you
can't tell with with that angle right there going
to have to back that up a little bit but it's the
now remember the NHL has their cameras right
along the goal line well that puck is that
Puck's over the line yeah and he's not that's
on side yeah it is if if if that indeed is the
one after video riew the play was
offside we have no goal okay the
time is to 6 44 Zev picks the puck
up at Center well that's a good play
right there in a very severe angle but he
just missed Kev radish knocked away but no
cigar snaking his way through Center and
into the zone of Montreal radish reaching
for it and a bouncing Puck bearing down on
an empty net it's in a high flip from the
veteran sard and it's got enough juice on
it to roll into the net much of the shrin
of the starting goal tender Peter morazzi
looked like the Hawks had an opportunity
getting the puck in there rolled off the
blade of of radish looked like and then
by the time it rolls up there sar's close to
him Montreal ends the game on a power play
and five unanswered goals this game much
closer than the final score indicates and